la diplomatie chinoise l'a bien compris
les talibans sont en passe de redevenir
les nouveaux maîtres de l'afghanistan
pékin plutôt en retrait jusqu'ici fait
désormais du dossier afghan une priorité
et veut mettre en place une politique de
bon voisinage avec les talibans je brade
les taliban afghan constitue une force
militaire et politique crucial en
afghanistan où on espère qu'ils pourront
jouer un rôle important dans le
processus de paix de réconciliation et
de reconstruction en afghanistan
nous espérons que les tags en donnerons
la priorité aux droits et aux intérêts
du pays du peuple qu'ils porteront haut
la bannière d'en parler de paix qu'ils
établiront l'objectif de l'appel et ils
donneront une image positive et qu'ils
mèneront une politique inclusive
les autorités chinoises n'ont jamais
considéré les talibans comme un
mouvement terroriste mais comme une
organisation religieuse radicale
la chine promet donc de ne pas
interférer dans les affaires afghanes
en réponse les insurgés assurent que le
sol afghan ne sera pas utilisée contre
la sécurité des autres pays
des voisins de l'afghanistan
particulièrement inquiet face à la
progression éclair des talibans les
insurgés se sont notamment emparés de
zone à l'extrême nord-est du pays
frontalière de la chine
la frontière terrestre entre les deux
pays est mince 76 km de longueur et 100
points de passage routiers
mais pékin redoute au xinjiang un
soutien extérieur à la minorité
musulmane ouïghoure
une reconquête du territoire afghan
qu'inquiète un autre pays de la région
l'inde allié de l'actuel gouvernement de
kaboul et des états unis et rival du
pakistan soutient de longue date du des
talibans le chef de la diplomatie
américaine tente de rassurer new delhi
nous sommes tous les deux attachées au
fait qu'il n'y a pas de solution
militaire au conflit qui affecte la
pianiste en afrique ça
jeudi une résolution pacifique qui exige
que les talibans et le gouvernement
afghan se met à table en retirons nos
forces à d'après une histoire et que le
temps ait d'autres retire leur force
nous restait très présent d'afghanistan
oui mais nous avons non seulement une
ambassade force là bas mais aussi des
programmes importants qu'ils continuent
de soutenir l'afghanistan sur le plan
économique est nul et ce grâce à l'aide
au développement mais aussi une
assistance sécuritaire à manchester
avec le retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan l'avancé sur kaboul des
talibans semble pour beaucoup
inéluctable le président afghan ashraf
ghani parle lui d'une invasion sans
précédent en termes d'échelle détendu et
de timing